Let's talk about the whistleblower.
Now, Donald Trump is actively putting in danger
the life of the Ukraine whistleblower according
to the whistle blowers attorneys.
Now, I told you the day that the Trump Ukraine
whistleblower scandal broke, that I hope that
the whistleblowers identity is protected because
if Trumpists find out who the person is, who's
whistleblower report triggered an impeachment
inquiry of their beloved Lord and savior Donald
Trump, that whistleblower his life is instantly
in danger.
And I'm not exaggerating when I say that,
I'm talking about a real and present danger
to that whistleblower's life.
And as if we needed any more evidence about
how Donald Trump feels about the whistleblower
and the whistleblower sources.
Remember that last week Donald Trump was caught
on a recording talking about, Oh uh, you know,
what about when we used to kill whistle blowers
or sources or whatever.
Remember this recording.
But basically that person never saw the report,
never saw the call, and he never saw the call,
heard something and decided that he or she,
you over the holidays are like, Oh this is
fine.
I want to know who's the person that gave
the whistleblower is the person that gave
the with lower the information cause that's
close to is fine.
You know what we used to do in the old days
where we responded, the spies and Teresa,
we used to handle it a little bit differently
than we do them.
Right?
Well,
it's getting much, much worse even in advance
of the individual being outed, which I hope
doesn't happen.
The whistle blowers lawyers have put out a
letter saying that Donald Trump is endangering
their client's life by calling them a trader
by issuing threats of retaliation by alluding
to what about execution of the whistleblower
or their sources.
The audio I played for you just now is referenced
in this letter and this is of course completely
counter to how whistleblowers are supposed
to be treated in the United States.
There is something called the whistleblower
protection act of 1989 but forget about that.
Even beyond that, there is the tradition of
how this country is supposed to respect whistleblowers.
That of course has been thrown completely
out the window by this administration much.
The way that respect and supportive of free
and independent press has been thrown out
the window completely by this administration
and as the whistle blowers lawyers point out
most countries where the leader of the country
treats a whistleblower the way Donald Trump
is treating this whistleblower.
Most of those countries are not democracies
and it is very ugly.
What is going on?
Consider how backwards this is.
Donald Trump said something incredibly disturbing
on a phone call with the Ukrainian president.
You could argue what Donald Trump was doing
was un-American or at least did not put the
interest of the American people as the number
one priority.
People heard the phone call and they reported
it to the whistle blower and Trump says that
is called spine.
This is someone, both the whistleblower and
the sources for the whistleblower.
These are people whose interests are conserving
the national security of the United States.
Their motivation is the maintaining of the
sovereignty of the United States over our
own elections without foreign influence.
The motivations of the whistle blower and
the sources are pro American.
They are about maintaining the systems and
processes that have been established in the
United States as the ones that we want.
Trump is trying to circumvent that, but yet
he's calling the people trying to maintain
these systems, spies, traders, enemies, all
of this stuff.
Now, I do have to go a step further here.
I get why the whistleblower, his identity
needs to be kept secret.
I hope that it is because that person's life
will be at risk if their identity is revealed.
They are at risk of death if their identity
goes public, but we have to recognize that
on the basis of the way that Donald Trump
has bamboozled and primed his followers, it
actually does help the Trump side for the
whistleblower's identity to be unknown because
of how they think.
They will build a character around the person,
crooked Hillary Pocahontas, whatever.
They will smear the whistleblower and the
whistleblower not only won't be present to
defend themselves, they won't even be a known
entity.
It will be Trump's case against this unknown
hidden person and it will become part of the
case for the defense of Trump's view.
Listen, this person won't even show their
face.
I go with Trump's view on this.
It's disgusting that this is the situation,
but sadly it is and you know that they will
use the whistle blowers as at least up until
this point and an MIT against them.
Let me know your thoughts about this.
I'm on Twitter at [inaudible] Pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
Make sure you're following me on that.
Twitch as well at twitch.tv/david Pacman.
We had a great live stream last night on Twitch.
I hope they'll catch
the
next one